>> Announcer: From the Library
of Congress in Washington DC.
>> Eleanor Billington: I'm
so honored to be here today
to introduce Luis Alberto Urrea, a
member of the Latino Literature Hall
of Fame and author of 16 books
include fiction, non-fiction,
short stories, and poetry.
Luis is a master storyteller who
moves effortlessly between genres.
He is perhaps best
known for his writing
about the U.S.-Mexican border born
in Tijuana to a Mexican father
and an American mother, Luis
understands the complexity
of border life and
the inherent tension
in living between two worlds.
His memoir, "Nobody's Son,
Notes from an American Life,"
won the 1999 American Book Award
and chronicles his early
childhood growing up in Tijuana
and his family's immigration
to the United States.
Published in 2004, "The
Devil's Highway," a harrowing,
non-fiction account of
Mexican immigrants lost
in the Arizona desert was a
finalist for the Pulitzer Prize.
His 2005 historical novel,
"The Hummingbird's Daughter,"
tells the story of his
great aunt Teresa Urrea,
and involved 20 years
of research and writing.
Along with "The Devil's Highway," it
was named the best book of the year
by many publications and won the
[inaudible] Prize in Fiction.
His most recent title, "The
Water Museum," is a finalist
for the Pen Faulkner Award and was
named the best book of the year
by The Washington Post and
Kirkus Reviews among many others.
Like much of Lisa's work,
these short stories,
these 13 short stories reflect
a sensitivity and allegiance
to both sides of his
family's heritage.
The collection exhibits
an impressive range
of style and subject matter.
From "Welcome to the Water
Museum," a dystopian tale of life
in the future where children
consider water an anomaly.
To "Carnations and the White Girl,"
"Vignettes of Grief of Loneliness,"
to the Edgar Award winning
"Amapola," which tells the story
of a teen romance with a very
dark twist to the comedic,
"Tape to the Sky," a look at an East
coast's academic's haphazard efforts
to reconcile with his
wife's infidelity.
The stories in "The Water
Museum" largely depict outsiders.
Individual displaced by
geography and poverty but also
by their grief and their longing.
While not every story is linked
in the collection, each one builds
on the previous, creating
a community of character
that is exquisitely drawn.
Their collective voice is haunting.
It reflects a desire for
connection despite societal
and cultural divides.
It is these moments of connection
between characters however brief
or imperfect that shine brightest
and convey Luis's self-proclaimed
interest in bridges not borders.
For the past three years,
we've had the pleasure
of working directly with Luis.
His book "Into the Beautiful
North" is part of the NEA Big Read,
the National Endowment for the
Arts Community Reading Initiative.
Communities across this country
from Los Angeles to Wichita,
Kansas to Trenton, New Jersey
have read his book as a part
of the NEA Big Read and six other
communities will do so this year.
We hear again and again
from these communities
about how much they love having
Luis at their Big Read events.
Big Read participants,
especially youth participants,
enjoy meeting and connecting
with him.
And this is no surprise to us.
He is not only a really
talented writer
but he is a gracious individual
and a very phenomenal speaker.
It is a huge privilege to
have him here with us today.
Please join me in welcoming
Luis to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Thank you.
That's awesome.
Buenos tardes, Washington DC.
Tijuana in the house.
I got to say that everywhere I go.
So, I thought I would
talk to you a little bit
about the writer's journey and what
led to my obsession with writing
and talking and leave some
time at the end because I love
to know what you'd like to know.
Sometimes people surprise me
with things they'd like to know.
So, I'll stop at about 4:35
or so and give the last 10,
15 minutes to questions
if you have them.
If not, we'll just leave [laughter].
But so I was born in
Tijuana, whoops,
and I was raised my first four years
in a neighborhood called
Colonia Independencia,
which means the Colony
of Independence.
Our street was Rampa Independencia.
The Ramp of Independence.
We have a theme.
And the Rampa was an
interesting place for me.
It was, if you could
sort of meld John Irving
and Garcia Marcus, it
was kind of that way.
It was a rough, rough dirt
street on the side of a hill
in Tijuana overlooking downtown.
From our grandmother's house,
we could see the movie theater
downtown called Cine de Forma
where we would go to
watch [inaudible] movies.
And the dirt street was so rough
that it could tear the oil pan
out of your car if you didn't
go very, very slowly on it.
And I want you to imagine
this place.
We had a little yellow house that
my grandfather built by hand.
And it was on a slope.
So, the second story was the ground
floor and you would go downhill
into the subsequent layers of the
house, which turned out to be one
of the controlling
metaphors for me as a writer.
I'm really fascinated by what one
of my students called under story.
You know, the use of the shadow
that is implied by what you write
and helps put the trance
on your reader.
And I think it's from that
house because you would go in,
the front of the house was
a wall with broken pieces
of Pepsi bottles stuck
in the cement, you know,
to cut up anybody who
tried to sneak in.
And then you would go down
these wooden steps into places
that were deep and shadowy where
the old family papers were,
old books were.
And there was a room that
was notoriously haunted
by an evil presence.
And sometimes the dogs
were down there.
So, it was an amazing kind of
a life long portrait for me
of the stuff that's hidden
down below the story.
This dirt street, later on when
I moved to the United States,
I went to Catholic school.
I wanted to be a Jesuit priest
when I was a little kid.
And back in those days,
Catholicism was not exactly the Pope
Francis style.
It was a little harsher.
So, the nuns would terrorize
us with terrible stories
about the Communists all
the time that, you know,
"The Communists don't
want you to love Jesus."
And they'd say, "Who
here loves Jesus?"
It was me and all the little
[inaudible], you know,
the little [inaudible] kids.
They were like, "Yo,
we totally love Jesus.
I'm down with Jesus, man."
They're like, "Really?
How much do you love Jesus?"
"Like totally.
I'm down with Jesus.
[inaudible].
Jesus is the Lord and
Savior [inaudible]."
And they'd say, "Really because the
Communists will rip your skin off
inch by inch."
And we'd say, "What?"
They'd say, "Oh, yes.
Yes. The Communists will put
little fish hooks in your flesh
and begin to rip your skin off.
Will you still love Jesus?
Because all you have to do
to stop the torment is say,
'I renounce Jesus Christ.'
How many of you now love the Lord?"
We'd be like, "I totally love him.
Like Jesus is wonderful."
That was the little world I was in.
And I was the dreamer
form the beginning.
I was the guy always in
trouble with the nuns.
I remember that they gave
us a little plastic statue
of the Virgin Mary.
She was in a little weird
modernistic shrine standing
there piously.
And I was a sci-fi freak.
And the shrine looked
like Rocket ship XM
from the science fiction movie.
And I kept launching the Virgin.
And I remember I got her about
this high and my eyes rose
and locked eyes with
Sister Bernita [laughter].
And back then they would flog you.
So, Sister Bernita came
after me with her yard stick.
And she latched onto my arm
and she began what I used
to call the [inaudible] two-step
where she'd whack you and you'd try
to run but you couldn't escape.
So, you'd go in a circle like
dancing a square dance of pain.
Anyway, in that atmosphere of
loving Jesus I was given a pamphlet
one day.
And the pamphlet, I still remember
quite vividly, was a cartoon.
And it said, "The highway to
hell and the path to redemption."
So, you opened the little booklet
and there is a beautiful drawing
of a late model maybe
1959 convertible.
And there's a dude driving
it looking like Don Draper.
He's got a little suit, a little
pork pie hat and he's waving.
And next to him there's a woman
with blonde bouffant in a red dress.
And they're going with the top down.
And it says, "The highway to hell."
And you turn the page and there's
this horrible rock strewn path
up a dark mountain covered in
cacti and threats everywhere.
Wolves, coyotes, skunks, snakes.
And that was the hard
path to heaven.
Which one are you going
to take [laughter]?
And for me it looked just
like Rampa Independencia.
So, I was like, cool,
I'm already there, man.
I'm on the path to heaven.
I'm in. Jesus loves me.
Now, just so the John Irving part.
You're probably wondering, where the
hell does John Irving fit into this?
Halfway down the Rampa, there
was a house down the slope.
And they had a bear.
How could you not be
a writer, right?
They had a bear that they
kept chained to a dead tree.
Poor bear.
Now I had this cousin who if anybody
has read "Into the Beautiful North,"
there's a character named
Atomico [phonetic] who is
like the world's toughest cholo.
It was based on my
cousin Ugo [phonetic].
Ugo Milan [phonetic].
Ugo Milan always talked like this.
When he was seven,
he talked like this.
Ugo Milan grew the first
[inaudible] mustache in the family
when he was 11 [laughter].
Oh, yeah. He had two whiskers.
He would stick them
down to hang down.
That was Ugo.
Ugo used to say to me, he used
to call me Louche [phonetic].
I hate to say this
because, you know,
dudes in Tijuana had
really cool nicknames.
There was a guy in our
neighborhood called El Frankenstein.
Just like El Lovo [phonetic],
El Tigre, and here I was Louche.
I was kind of lacking
in my machismo.
But anyway, he'd say to me, "Louche,
you want to go feed the bear?"
And I'd be like, "Yeah, Ugo,
let's go feed the bear."
So, we'd go out with this
little sister Margarita.
And there was a ritual.
You couldn't just go feed the bear.
First, you had to get
stale tortillas.
Then you had to go outside
and turn on the radio
until James Brown came on.
And then you had to try to get on
the good foot in the rocks and dirt
without falling down to
dance to James Brown.
And then we would go
in line down the hill.
And we would get to this poor bear.
And Ugo would summon him.
You know, "Hey, bear."
And it would look up at him.
And he would fly that stale
tortillas like Frisbees.
And the bear would catch them.
And it would eat them.
And sometimes it would wave.
Seriously.
It would speak some bear.
You know? Farther down the
hill, believe it or not,
somebody had built on top of
a dirt cliff, little castle.
Castle complete with turrets
and like archer slots in Tijuana
and they painted it bright yellow,
which I thought was really cool.
At the bottom of that, there was a
vertical shaft that led to the sewer
and flood control tunnels.
And Ugo would always fake
me out and say, "Hey Louche.
Look up at the castle."
I'd look at the castle and he'd
grab me and throw me down the hole
and then he'd come down after
me and then we'd catch her.
And we would walk underground
through Tijuana.
So, you can see the deeper story
was really interesting to me.
What's down in the shadows?
You know? And one time, I've
written about this elsewhere,
but we were down there
and we started
to smell something really bad.
And then we heard something
making these sounds,
you know [strange sounds].
Like that.
We thought, oh my god, what is that?
I watch those monster movies.
I thought it was the blob.
And so she was holding
onto his shirt.
I was holding on to her sweater.
We're walking in and it's getting
louder and louder and stinkier
and stinkier, and he pulled
out a cigarette lighter he
had stolen from his mom.
And he lit it.
And it was a dead pig
full of maggots.
And we were just like ahh
looking at this thing.
And I still remember him.
He looked at us and he
goes, "Ain't nothing.
It's death.
Death don't got nothing
to do with us."
And we walked out to
the light [laughter].
You know? You got to write.
And I want to just
put this as an aside.
And since we are in DC and
this is an election year,
I just want to say Ugo
Milan, if you ever watch TV,
you know the The Dog
Whisperer, right?
Cesar Milan.
Get out of here.
That's not Cesar Milan.
His name is Cesar Milan.
He is a cousin of my cousins.
He is from [inaudible].
And I just want to say, the man came
to the United States undocumented.
He did. No papers.
His only skill was
talking to dogs [laughter].
And now he is a millionaire
media star.
All right?
So, America, I don't
care what you hear
about America not working,
still works.
Still works.
[ Applause ]
So, just briefly I just, you know,
want to give you a little more
about this writing thing.
Two things.
One was his mother.
Ugo Milan's mother was
named Tia Flaca [phonetic],
which means Aunt Skinny.
Tia Flaca was in fact skinny.
Lifelong diabetic.
Everybody in my family.
I think everybody in
Mexico, diabetic.
And I grew up watching her
getting her shots every day.
They gave them to her in her leg.
In her thigh.
And picture this woman.
She was stylish in her own way.
She wore cat eye glasses.
Remember those?
With glitter in them.
And being diabetic she had
gone blind in her left eye.
And so it was always a
little squinchy [phonetic].
And she always smoked menthol
cigarettes around the clock
but always clamped
them on the left side.
So, there was always smoke.
It looked like it was
coming out of her bad eye.
There was smoke coming out.
And she controlled us with stories.
She lied in other words to
make us do what she wanted.
For example, she hated
a mess in the house.
She did not, she figured, you
know, I'm a working woman.
I don't have time to clean the
house, so don't make a mess.
She used to go every morning
to a tuna cannery to work
in San Diego and come
back exhausted.
She was not going to clean house.
Now, my grandmother,
her mom, and by the way,
if you're asking yourself why
does this dude look Irish,
I will tell you because
my grandmother
from [inaudible] was named
Guadalupe Murray [phonetic].
So, red haired, blue-eyed
Irish Mexican lass.
So, we called her Mama Lupita.
Mama Lupita was a lapsed Catholic.
She didn't want to deal with church.
Mass. Get out of here.
You know, she had better
things to do.
So, she would every Friday fry
a fish for the young priest.
And he'd walk down from
the church and eat his fish
and get out of our house.
And she got these ideas that
you could do symbolic things
that God liked like burn incense.
She thought, "Yeah.
Yeah. God likes incense.
So, I'll burn some
incense and he will see,
you know, house is full of smoke."
And then she realized he could
count the cones of incense.
So, she would do like
20 cones a day.
Right? But it never occurred to her
to actually put them in saucers.
So, she put the cones on
window ledges and on the piano.
So there were burns
everywhere and stains
of the resin all over the house.
But she also did not like to
get rid of the cone of ash.
I think she was figuring God
is going to keep a tally.
You know God has a little
check that says, "Ah ha.
Lupita did 27.
That's good.
It erases a couple of sins."
Right? "Oh, she was
down to 15 today."
Well, you know?
So, the house was full of
cones of ash from the incense.
And I didn't know what they were.
I saw them and I was thinking,
"That is really weird.
What is that stuff?"
And remember, Tia Flaca
didn't want a mess.
She didn't want to be
sweeping up ashes, right?
So, I stupidly went to her.
I said, "Tia, [foreign
language spoken] Tia.
All those cones every place?"
And she said, "Oh."
She got very serious.
"[inaudible].
Those are the souls of
dead men [laughter]."
She said, "If you break them, the
house is going to fill with spirits.
Don't touch."
So, there was no mess [laughter].
And the other little
thing, which is truly one
of the I think deepest inspirations
for writing in my life was this.
She didn't like me
going out on the street.
It was rough.
People shooting each other.
Cars. Who knows what.
Dogs [inaudible].
So, my dad and my mom would leave.
My mom worked in a department store.
He also worked in the tuna cannery.
And Tia Flaca would leave later in
her '56 Chevy driving across, right?
And there was I.
And she would tell me,
"Meijo, I don't want you
to go in the street today.
Stay inside."
They had a phrase [foreign
language spoken].
It was like, you know, you're a
street dog, which I thought was kind
of bad ass frankly, but,
and I would be all repentant
like I had been with the nuns.
"No, Tia. I won't go.
I promise."
She says, "You promise me."
"No, I promise.
I swear. I'm going to stay and
watch like Jeopardy with grandma.
OK? It's OK."
And so she'd go to work.
And as soon as she was
gone, out in the street
because my little pals
were out there.
We would play marbles.
[inaudible] we'd call them.
Right? And you could get, you
could get a kite for a penny.
So, we're flying kites.
And you could buy candies, like
five, six candies for a penny.
We were in heaven.
There were dogs out there.
And we could try to spin tops but
you couldn't do it in the the dirt
but we'd keep trying all day long.
Just stupid stuff.
And I was out there with my
homies, shooting marbles, right?
Not paying any attention.
And all of the sudden they
all jumped up and ran away.
And I was like, "What the heck?"
You know? Where'd they go?
And I look up and here comes Flaca
driving home in her '56 Chevy.
Smoke pouring out of her eye.
I thought, "Oh, no."
Oh my god.
You know, and you start
confessing your sins.
"Jesus, I did lie to my
Tia, but, you know, come on.
Give me a break.
You died for me."
And she pulls up and I
stand up and I'm ready.
The worst punishment, those of
you with Mexican or Latina moms
or aunts know what I'm going to say.
The worst punishment than the yard
stick is what we call the chankla
[phonetic], which is the old
lady gets out her slipper
and wails on you with it.
And the funny thing
about them when they do
that is they get very formal.
So, you become thou.
And as they hit you,
they explain every point
of their agenda [laughter].
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
They get more and more obscene
while they're calling you thou.
And you're like raining slippers.
And then the most diabolical
thing is they all have this eye.
They could pass for the NFL.
Because they let you
go and you start to run
and slosh [phonetic], bam.
They always get you at the last
second on the back of the head.
You know it's true.
So, I was waiting for my punishment.
And I thought, "I'm going
to take it like a man."
My dad's big thing was "Be a man."
So, I thought, OK, I'm
going to show him I'm a man.
And she got out of the car.
And she took her cigarette.
And she said, "Aye Luis.
Didn't I tell you to
stay out of the street?"
I said, "Yes, Tia."
"Didn't I tell you to stay inside?"
"Yes." "And what did you tell me?"
"That I would."
"And what did you do?"
"I went outside."
"And why did you go outside?"
"I don't know."
And she said, "I don't care.
I give up.
I don't care.
I can't control you anymore.
Do what you got to do, meijo.
You want to be out on the street?
Stay out on the street.
I've given up.
I'm going inside."
So, off she went with her cigarette.
And I thought, "Oh, yes.
Thank you God.
You love me."
And she got right to the door.
And she said, "Except there's
one thing I want to say to you."
And I said, "Yeah?"
And she came back.
And she said, "Look around."
So, I looked around.
"Look behind us."
I looked behind us.
She said, "You see that Tijuana
has hills all around it?"
I said, "Yeah.
Yeah." "There's mountains
even all around Tijuana."
"Yeah, Tia."
"Have you ever gone
up there, meijo?"
Duh. "No."
"Do you know what's up there?"
"No, Tia."
"Marijuana farms."
I was like, "Really?"
"Oh, yeah."
I thought, OK, you know, grown
ups are always saying weird stuff
to you.
I thought OK.
She said, "Do you know
how they grow marijuana?"
I said, "No, how do
they grow marijuana?"
"Oh, well, every afternoon around
now, the narcos send out trucks
with men with rifles in
the trucks and they drive
around Tijuana hunting for
little blonde boys playing
in the street [laughter].
And they use their guns.
And they take those
little boys prisoner.
And they take them to
the top of the mountain.
And they force them to grow
marijuana at gunpoint."
And then she says, "But it's OK.
Stay out here if you
want to [laughter]."
So, come on.
I went inside.
So, you know, I was deeply infected
with storytelling from the get go.
And I truly loved it.
And a little bit more of a
spiritual aspect that I just can't,
because it's not all fun and
games but there's a lot of beauty
in our roots and we
don't always know.
Sometimes, you know, we
think our roots are shameful.
I'm not going to get political,
but look at the Presidential
campaign this year.
You know? And people tell
you that you're no good
or your ancestors are no good
or you come from a neighborhood
with no hope and nothing but
terrible crime and murder.
You know, sometimes it's all
about the beauty of those places
that someone tells
you aren't beautiful.
And for me Colonia
Independencia was beautiful, man.
And the best part for me,
I've talked about this
before, was the tortilla place.
One of the times they
would let me go
out is they would give me some
money, and they'd say, "Luis,
go buy a kilo of tortillas."
Then I was cool, man,
because I'd walk
up the hill toward
the tortilla place.
And anybody who knows a
Mexican village or has old time
because now they make
tortillas with machines.
You don't get this anymore.
But from a certain distance
you hear the ladies doing this
[patting hands].
Right? It's like they're
applauding you.
Yes. Yes [laughter].
And it gets louder and
louder the closer you get.
You start smelling the maize.
And then you hear the radio.
And then you hear them
laughing and talking.
And it's like entering to me,
it was like entering this
weird state of grace.
Like it's so magical it still
chokes me up to this day to think
about being this little guy walking
up to the tortilla [inaudible]
and stepping in this
rough, super hot room.
Four or six Mexican women,
many of them indigenous [patting
hands], making tortillas.
And the radio is blaring and there's
a [inaudible] and it's burning hot.
And you're watching them.
And they're sweating.
And even as a little kid,
you realize that their flavor
is going into the food.
Right? They're making this thing.
Their sweat is falling into it.
And I even at seven, eight, was
having a super erotic moment
because I was looking up
at them thinking, "Oh, oh,
you dusky princesses [laughter]."
Right? I was like, "I
shall marry all six of you.
Just wait for me though.
I got to catch up, but I'm coming."
And they were so sweet because,
you know, the older women
in our cultures have so
many codes of generosity
and kindness and strength.
Not just [foreign language spoken].
And they would look at me
and they would go nuts.
[ Foreign Language Spoken ]
The little blonde boy
[foreign language spoken].
I was like, "Yeah.
I am hot. Yes."
And they'd be like,
"[foreign language spoken]."
And I'd be like, "Dang
right I want a tortilla."
And I'd say, "Si.
Por favor."
And they would take a hot tortilla.
And they'd put a little salt in
it, roll it up, and give it to me.
Come on. And then on a really
good day they had butter.
And they'd put butter on it
and roll it up and give it,
I was just like, mm-hmm, yeah.
And then they would
give me that hot kilo.
And I would carry it back
warming my body to feed my family.
Holy cow. How powerful is that?
And I carry them with me.
I carry them with me.
And the women that I
saw when I was a kid.
My upbringing was absent
men pretty much.
My dad was out and
about being a man.
And he'd come home and
check on me and make sure,
want to see if I was being
a man or not [laughter].
And he was never happy with
how much of a man I was.
But to watch the miracle
I think of the daily life.
I became kind of obsessed
with capturing the daily life.
Watching my godmother garden.
Watching her daughters
sort the pinto beans.
This act that was so graceful
and so invisible, nobody thought
about it or saw it except me.
I would sit all morning and watch
and how they would put the beans
on the table and start sifting them
around and raking the good beans
into a pot they held between their
knees and without even looking,
flick away little pebbles and
sticks without seeing them.
But they knew they were
there until they had the pot.
And then they could
make food to feed us.
And how I would try to
tell them my newest poems.
And they would say,
"[foreign language spoken].
You talk so pretty."
Wow, man. Writing, right?
Later on we moved up to a little
white, working class suburb.
I was telling people earlier today,
I had never seen lawns
until the fifth grade.
I saw grass.
And I remember thinking, "Wow, these
white dudes are billionaires, man.
They pour water on their
yards and they have grass."
And I also ate sliced bread.
I grew up eating peanut butter
sandwiches on corn tortillas.
We called it "la peanut butter."
There I was in this new
world and I have to tell you
that this big transformation
happened in the fifth grade.
I did all this new stuff.
I had a very strong Tijuana accent
until I moved to that neighborhood.
I have relatives still
talk like this.
OK? If I go to Mexico very
long, I come back like,
my friends think I'm kidding.
They're like, "What is this man?"
"What? [inaudible]."
But we got up there and it
started changing immediately.
And I know exactly when it changed.
They didn't know what my name was.
Right? So, I was, of course,
urine, diarrhea, urethra.
They didn't know what
the heck it was.
They started calling me unreal,
which I thought was awesome.
For a guy that wanted
to be a famous author
or be in Led Zeppelin,
it didn't matter.
Unreal. Cool name.
So, I joined the Boy Scouts.
And the Boy Scouts were
heaven for a kid like me.
Going camping and stuff.
And my old man did not approve.
He didn't like it.
He'd be like, "Meijo,
[inaudible] Boy Scouts.
You wore green shorts, meijo."
I was like, "Yeah, Dad."
"You wear green shorts
and long socks
and you wear a handkerchief
on your neck."
I said, "Yeah, it's my
neckerchief [phonetic].
It's got a slide and everything."
And my dad said, "If you want to be
a man, join the Army [inaudible]."
And I was like, "Dad,
I'm in fifth grade."
It was always about
being a man, you know?
But here is where the change came.
And I think about this a lot.
Almost every time I turn
on the TV right now.
I was with my boys, my new
homies, and we had been camping
and doing all this stuff.
The Bat Patrol.
Troop 260.
Bat Patrol.
And we were in the bathroom.
Fifth grade.
About to head into sixth grade.
And everybody is in there
doing their business.
And there was this one kid,
bright red hair, freckles.
I mean the classic suburban
white boy, you know?
And they're all my buds.
And he turns to me and
he says, "Hey, Unreal."
And I said, "Yeah."
And he said, "You know
what you are, man?"
I said, "No, what am I?"
He said, "You're a greaser."
And they all turned to
me and started laughing.
And I said, "I'm a what?"
He said, "You're a
greaser, wet back."
And all my homies started
in, "Greaser wet back.
Greaser wet back."
And they all walked out together.
And I was standing there.
And, you know, you're a kid.
You internalize it, right?
And you think, "Greaser wet back."
I thought, nobody told us
that we're wet with grease
that only these folks in the
north part of the city can see it.
And I remember taking
off my shirt and trying
to find the grease on my undershirt.
That was a shock.
And my cousins would come up from
Mexico and they couldn't figure
out the whole dynamic
of race and so forth
because they weren't
poor kids like me.
They were actually kind
of royalty down there.
And in Southern California they
had all kinds of names for us
but the one that was
kind of creative,
they could call us taco benders
because there is a nice little
u-shape in the taco, right?
It's pretty creative.
And I was walking down the
street with my cousin Jamie
who didn't speak English.
He was a Beatles fiend.
He knew English from
phonetic recounting
of Beatles songs [inaudible].
And he would sing,
you know [inaudible].
You know? Old [inaudible].
So, we're walking down the street
and a guy in a truck pulled up
and yelled, "Hey, taco bender."
And he said, "What you want
cheeseburger [laughter]?"
His one English lesson.
So, words meant so much to me.
They always meant so much to me.
And the thing I want to leave
with you before I go to questions
or comments if you have
any, is that at that moment
when I suddenly internalized
shame, I was so shocked.
All of the sudden people
didn't like Mexicans.
I thought everybody loved us.
I thought Tia Flaca was awesome.
I thought my grandma was cool.
I thought Rampa Independencia
was cool.
I thought Ugo Milan was super cool
and all of the sudden we weren't.
And that was a great
and tremendous shock.
So, everything I held
sacred was suddenly trash
in the culture in which I was in.
And it took me a long time to
figure out how to deal with that.
Thank god for words.
When I got to college,
Southern California
in those days was not a
place to expect to learn
that there were Latino writers or
women writers or black writers.
I get to college and
they're like, "OK.
We're going to be reading
[inaudible], Carlos Fuentes."
I said, "Who?
What?" What a miracle.
So, I felt like I got kind of
atomized and then reintegrated.
And something, it was good.
It was like a transporter beam
in Star Trek or something.
I felt like my cells
were purified in a way.
And so I decided what I had
to do was do a literature
of witness for the rest of my life.
I was a poor boy like I told you.
I wanted to be Stephen King.
I wanted to be Robert
Plant or Steve McQueen.
I just wanted a bunch
of cars and a plane.
And for a long time I
thought if I wrote love poems
to my girlfriend Collette,
that would happen.
Wrong. But I realized
that I wanted to witness.
And that meant witness everybody.
And sometimes it means having
to put your prejudice aside,
because I'm loaded with it,
class rage and prejudice,
and try to see everybody
that you're writing about
and give them a fair reading.
And that can be really hard,
but that has been my
obsession ever since.
So, that's a little bit
of where I came from.
That and about 300 notebooks
full of really bad writing.
And here we are now.
So, thanks for listening.
And if you have any
questions [inaudible].
[ Applause ]
There are mics.
>> Female Speaker 1: Hi.
A fellow Chicagoan.
And Chicago has a great tradition
of Mexican American writers, Luis.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Yeah.
>> Female Speaker 1: And I want
to know, what are you students,
what kind of stories are your
students bringing to you?
Is it anywhere near the same
or has too much changed?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
That's a great question.
I, oddly enough our school has kind
of a difficult time I think
getting Latino students to come
to our English Department.
So, every spring they ask me to
do an Introduction to Latino Lit
and it's amazing because
those kids are like me.
They have no idea.
So, I hit them with
Gloria [inaudible].
You know, and then we
just make the circuit
through as many authors
as I can get to them.
And in the creative writing
aspects, I do graduate workshops
like in the fall, well,
I'm here with you instead
of doing my day job, right?
So, I just teach one class,
which is a graduate workshop,
which every year, it keeps
getting bigger and bigger.
And I had to stop it this year
because I said there are too
many people to fit in the room,
and we can't possibly
do a workshop now.
But the subject matter is
fascinating and multi-faceted.
And, in fact, there's
a young Chicana
who just wrote this amazing super
powerful piece and didn't know
if the workshop could
handle it or not.
And she sent it to me, which
really moved me almost to tears
that she would have me look at her
secret story first and trust me
to tell her if it was safe or not
and should I put a trigger warning
on it or not show it at all.
And it's very powerful
what she talks about
but I told her, I think
you can do this.
I think if you feel good about
it, I'll back you up on this,
and I think it's really good.
So, you know, the subject
matter is all over the place.
And I am trying to just help people
find the story they want to tell.
I think it's difficult when you're
just starting to know what you want
to write, you know, and
how you want to write it.
I was talking with Kelly earlier
about a writer named Nnedi Okorafor.
If you know Nnedi, she
just won the Hugo Award.
She's Nigerian.
And she came to our
school to write a memoir.
And over the couple of
years she started to realize
that there's very little science
fiction and speculative fiction come
out of African [inaudible].
And she decided to
write science fiction
with Nigerian folklore in it.
And, you know, created
her own genre by accident.
So, sometimes it takes a step
and then you might surprise
yourself where you end up going.
So, I'm trying to stay as flexible
as I can and sort of help move them
in the direction that moves them.
And it's not always what a
wise career move would dictate.
But, you know, your soul
knows what it wants.
And I tell them, you know, you may
be in for 40 years of suffering
and obscurity but it's worth it if
that's what you really need to say.
So, I don't know if that
answers your question, but, hi.
>> Female Speaker 2: Me?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Yeah.
Oh, is there somebody,
oh, I'm sorry.
Let me go over there
and I'll come back.
>> Female Speaker 2: OK.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Hi.
Sorry.
>> Female Speaker 3:
Do you have a favorite,
do you have a favorite
story you made as a child?
And what is it about?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Oh my goodness.
Probably not as a child.
I think later on I
have a lot of stories.
Like this book "Hummingbird's
Daughter" that I did and "Queen
of America, The Sequel"
took 26 years to write.
And they began as stories
that Tia Flaca told.
So, I would say probably
that because I've carried
them with me my whole life.
Yeah.
>> Female Speaker 2: Hi.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Hi.
>> Female Speaker 2: I wanted to
ask you, who are you writing for?
You know who is your
intended audience?
Or who is it that you are
writing for [inaudible]?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Who am I writing for?
>> Male Speaker 1: For himself.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
That's a great question.
My wife. She's always
my first reader.
And I can tell you
when I had been working
on "Hummingbird's Daughter" a
decade plus, and I gave her a draft,
she's a reporter, and I
said, "Here, check it out.
What do you think?"
And she gave it back and
said, "I don't like it?"
What? And all my friends
took her aside and said, "No.
No. No. You're supposed to
tell him it's brilliant.
He doesn't actually
want your opinion."
But it was great because I
realized I could always trust her
to tell me the truth.
So, I think, you know,
beginning with Cindy.
But also I feel responsible
to the ancestors
and to people who are gone.
And I have honestly a lot, I've
written about this else where,
but in my mind I'm thinking of
a hard working woman like my mom
or my Tia Flaca who has had a
hellish day and is tired of putting
on the brave face every morning and
just looking forward to getting home
and getting that soak in the
tub and she opens my book.
And I want to give her the
best I can possibly give her.
So, you know, I think those things.
Hi.
>> Male Speaker 1: Hello.
I really enjoyed listening to you.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Thank you.
>> Male Speaker 1: You know,
you mentioned you're part
Irish and part Mexican.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Yes.
>> Male Speaker 1: So, my
question is, this [inaudible]
or this combination, how far
do you think is the cause
of your boisterous way of
putting things [laughter]?
>> Luis Alberto Urrea: Oh, I
thought I was rather somber.
You know, I don't know.
My mother was from English
and Hungarian stock.
And she was, the family
came from the South.
They were Virginians that lost
everything in the Civil War
and headed north to New York.
And my father actually, my
grandmother is Irish/Mexican.
My Grandfather Urrea was Basque.
And Urrea in Basque
means the golden man.
Yeah. Yeah.
So, I just think it was, my
mother used to say to me,
"It's no wonder you're
so moody, dear boy."
So, I think that the
general [inaudible]
of my character may just
be that plus just relief
that I survived, you know?
And it doesn't stink to have
your dreams coming true.
And to be able to know
that I can be here with you
because I typed is unbelievable.
And, you know, you meet your heroes.
I'm a fan more than, I never get
up in the morning and think, "Yes,
I'm a professional author."
I get up because I'm
insane for books.
And I confessed to
somebody in the green room
that I've been doing the Tucson
Festival of Books every year.
I'm one of the founding authors.
Right? And one of the other
founding authors was Elmore Leonard.
Oh, you know?
And for six years I would look at
Elmore Leonard in the green room.
And Cindy would say, "Go say hi."
"No. No [laughter]."
"Come on."
"No. It's Elmore Leonard.
I can't." And the last year before
he passed away, he started noticing,
"There's that idiot staring at me."
And so the last year, he
got up to go to his reading,
and he was walking out, and
he stopped at our table.
And he looked at me and went, "Hey."
And he kept going [laughter].
So, there's a certain element
of joy I think in all of this
for me though, you know, she'll tell
you I complain all the time, but.
>> Male Speaker 1: Thank you.
>> Luis Alberto Urrea:
Thank you, sir.
I guess that's it.
And we're right on the button.
So, thank you.
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
>> Announcer: This has
been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.